uh there was that people on the floor a
lot of people they were like you know
hiding and as I was going around they
told me to get away you know to move out
and I kept on telling them I'm looking
for my daughter my mom and I were in
Johnson Murphy shopping and I don't know
where I heard about like 10 pops go off
and I look at the customer next to me as
I was like was that gunshots and he was
like no it's probably just construction
or something and then like her 10 15
more shots go off uh and so I ran to the
front of the store and were like no
that's shooting and we see the guy
there's this guy dressing all black
wearing a vest has an assault rifle and
he's just shooting at people
right across he was at like Francesca's
area shooting at people so we we got
everyone in the store in the back of the
store and just camped out there for the
time being just got out like 30 minutes
ago